check the legitimacy of those balanced
issues
and what's the time frame for you guys
to be able to finish counting
i assume you guys been doing it this
morning we're going to continue to
count the ballots as quickly as we can
without sacrificing accuracy as we have
from the beginning
that's where we're at we're going to be
we'll be done you know when we get done
because we are we are we still have
balance that we're
we're scanning today um that there'll be
another update as i said
and we'll continue to do as we have been
doing ensuring that
the ballots that we have are counted as
quickly and as accurately as possible
we are in the process right now of
of counting just like we were yesterday
and the day before
it's the same process we are counting
ballots
and we will continue to do that as
quickly
as possible without sacrificing accuracy
is there anything further you can say
two more questions
[Music]
but how many segregated ballots do you
have
we are going to continue i don't have
that i don't have that number
we're going to continue we are going to
continue
to count the ballots until
they're all done and in a very in
in a way that people like as we have
been doing
for these past few days we're going to
get it done as quickly as possible
and it will be accurate and we'll come
out and if we have something to tell you
you'll you'll know we we have beat we
have we sit at the return board
you've been on our website the numbers
get updated
there is a live stream everybody can
watch
it's a very transparent process it's a
process that
has been working for the past few days
it's the same process we're just going
to keep counting
we're going to keep counting we're going
to keep we're going to keep counting
this week that's it thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
i'm
okay